right now you're tuned into either fox
or cnn
whatever your cult little tickles your
tribal mind [ __ ]
you're watching that and you're going oh
boy is he going to win is he going to
win venetia's mother is on a [ __ ]
defibrillator right now right now
so um do the right thing and don't vote
and let's try to get yeah do the right
thing do not vote we want to try to get
a dictator in to end
voting and voting that should be great
yeah that's it we don't want any more
interference from the russians the only
way to do that is have a dictator so
there's no elections anymore yeah so
we'll see so maybe this might be the
last year with the electoral college i
mean go google the electoral college we
barely talked about it
so go google what it's about we got a
youtube video that we could post i mean
because we just want to go wild the
truth is i
we [ __ ] doing this podcast just to
tell you i echo what yoni says
don't vote unless you're in florida ohio
then your vote kind of maybe matters but
the truth of the situation is this
is it's probably all rigged anyway and
there's no way they're counting all
these [ __ ] votes
with all the election meddling they
don't have the time to do that the
winner has been predetermined and joe
biden and donald trump know who it is we
don't know who it is but we'll make
they'll make believe like it was a
scandal they already know who the
[ __ ] they already know the president
is
all these people are friends trump and
biden and obama and clinton they're all
friends
they all know each other they're all
[ __ ] elitist they don't care about
any of us
but go ahead vote if you've got nothing
to do get out get some fresh air
go vote i mean oh here here's another
fun fact it's the 100th year
it's the 100th year that women are
allowed to vote in the usa
august 1920 the 19 in august of 1920
is when the 19th amendment was passed
and women were granted the right to vote
and just a hundred years later
after women have the right to vote our
country is in chaos and about to
deteriorate and crumble
to and wash away by the ocean so there
you go if you're living in a
non-american country do what you can to
make sure women can't vote anymore or
else you're going to become us
wait but wait a second you forgot about
you forgot about one fun fact
what's the [ __ ] 60 of white women i
think at least
maybe even more voted for trump last
time it's what it is so
do you really want to take away the vote
because that might have what tipped the
scale for dottie d
oh yeah so then just for this election
they can't no i'm kidding that was
that's a beautiful thing 100 year
anniversary congrats to women yeah
congrats
yeah congrats to biological women and
women who
are trans all within
women women and we're talking about
people with uteruses and people without
all women all women now here's the deal
um i think it was i think it's really uh
an interesting fact that was a fun one
from 2016 for me
yes that a woman was running and most
white women did not vote for
my stepmother did not vote so
v how can we how can we get women to get
along because
when you guys get unified that one or
two times that's happened
in history yeah yeah like how do you how
did you because i'll tell you what
getting naked and having car to be a
spokesperson just ain't working
so what else can we do yeah is cardi b
gonna sit down
with uh joe biden one more time i hope
for a hard hitting interview that for
the people again yeah i hope so
yeah or yeah so what can what can what
can we do
as a woman what can we do to women to
get them to vote for
biden and uh and harris the first
african-american president who's not
african-american
that's what it is well i think that's
pretty dope that there's there's a vp
who's a female so that's number that's
dope can we offer them [ __ ] scented
candles
or something from qvc something people
money talks it's the economy stupid what
do white women like they like [ __ ]
they like jeggings and they like scented
candles
what can we give them i think that some
women just don't see themselves
represented in uh government so it's
like kind of weird so they're like oh
i'm just gonna do what i'm used to
so i think that people need to give uh
them a chance i mean there's a lot of
change that is happening
and your vote does matter yes electoral
votes it's [ __ ] but
you know when you go to vote there's
popular votes on
on the other people that are on the
ballot so guys
i think that you should vote it's not
just the president when you say
when you say you want them to vote do
you or do you mean it the same way lady
gaga does just vote whoever it
whoever it is for no i mean so what i
say
no no no because i want to ask lady gaga
she said make sure you go out there and
vote
so lady gaga are you talking to the
people who are going to vote trump
should they vote
do you want them to vote you want them
to stay home they would actually be more
effective if like the entire capital was
like look
you're voting yeah that's what i that's
what i've been saying
that's why i'm so angry this part
because i've had enough of the [ __ ]
it's like
we know when the celebrities say vote
just tell us
that you want us to vote for biden just
be honest
yeah be honest please that's all i'm
asking you would do yourself so much
better
[ __ ] lying like you're all they're
always lying
i think no matter who wins they
shouldn't allow be allowed to tweet
yes i that's one thing i would say i
don't think you should be able to
president can't have twitter you can't
have twitter anymore so it can't be like
you
you we can't put you can't maybe start a
world war when you're taking a [ __ ]
yeah that can't be it can't be i can't
believe i'm bored taking a [ __ ] let me
tweet this out about king jung foon
yeah whatever who's definitely dead and
being propped up whoever the people
responsible
for making uh kim jong-un stay alive
when he's already dead are the same
people that created joe biden
it's the same thing whoever that makeup
artist is you deserve a
[ __ ] award because kim jong-un's been
dead since april and joe biden's been
dead since about the late 80s and long
long live ali wong she doesn't believe
communism could ever happen in america
yeah well it's happening
uh ally and it's happening soon yeah we
really hope you enjoyed that episode
whatever it was about this is just a
stock thing that we're taping on to
every episode
so go make sure you rate review us
subscribe uh turn on your notifications
get jiggy with it and go to
patreon.comridgeboys where things get
really wild